عندما رأيته لأول مرة ، لم أكن أعرف
بالضبط ما كان عليه ، ولكن بعد ذلك عندما رأيته
كان أحمر وبرتقاليًا لامعًا وأصفرًا ،
اكتشفت بسرعة أنه
أخطبوط بطانية
ربما يكون الحيوان الأكثر أناقة الذي رأيته على
الإطلاق  كانت تلك البطانية تتجه
لأعلى ولأسفل في عمود الماء
وتدور حولها أمرًا مذهلاً ،
فأنا أصرخ طوال الوقت ، لذا كان الأمر
مثيرًا حقًا لأنهم
نادرون جدًا
بحجم يشبه حبة الجوز الكبيرة
، يشبه الرأس نوعًا ما يشبه أذرعهم ،
لدي الكثير من الناس يعلقون
على أنه ليس أخطبوطًا حقيقيًا وليس
به ثمانية أذرع ، بل إنه في
الواقع يشبه كثيرًا أقصر بكثير
وهم "  إعادة مخبأة في ذلك الرأس
[الموسيقى]
بطريقة ما أنا أشبه
بمغناطيس الأنواع النادرة قليلاً ولكن من حيث
رأسيات الأرجل ، هذا بالتأكيد
أندر ما رأيته
وسأكون بصراحة تجربة لمرة واحدة في
العمر كما أشك بشدة في أنني
سوف ترى واحدة من هؤلاء مرة أخرى  لذلك أنا
أعتبر نفسي محظوظًا جدًا
[موسيقى] ،
فنحن نستثمر الكثير من المال والجهد
في استكشاف الفضاء
بينما لا يزال لدينا الكثير من الأرض
التي لا تزال غير مكتشفة ، يقوم
العلماء في الواقع
باكتشافات كل يوم كما لو أننا ما زلنا نطلق
أسماء جديدة  الأنواع المحيطية
لا يزال هناك الكثير لنتعلمه